jelena who was what her Epstein's
girlfriend madam madam whatever you want
to call it that helped out without
actually called routing bottom girls you
were telling a certain so want you talk
about that so shout out to yahko
billions out there fighting sex
trafficking learn something interesting
this morning so to give you guys a
little bit of context this particular
lady maxwell lalalala maxwell happened
to be the the bottom girl or the madame
the mistress for Jeffrey Epstein she's
been in hiding nobody has known where
she's had there was talk to that she was
in the South of France and stuff she was
hiding somewhere around the world she
was just arrested in I think it was New
Hampshire
she was arrested in New Hampshire nobody
knows how she got there I think that
that we could have that conversation of
if she was in another country maybe
Interpol scoops her up they put her on a
plane make sure she touches down in New
Hampshire and lets the CIA or the FBI
take over but she is the lady that would
groom all of the young girls for Epstein
she was the one that would even help
recruit all of the guys so basically
she's known in the industry as a bottom
girl which basically is the buffer
between Epstein and the police she's the
one that's out there doing the
recruiting as as you pointed out earlier
she's probably more of a criminal than
even just she's by far more Brooklyn
because she is setting up the girls to
tell him what to do before they go into
the room here's what I want you and then
they're getting the fourteen-year-old
girls to bring other friends and hang
him $300 to recruit other girls that had
coming to this place and then going
through the mess and you know shout out
to one of our girls that we work with in
PHP her name is Marlene Marlene guy town
marlene built or gate on first time I
sit down with in 2008 2009 I said
Marlene what are some of your goals in
life she was 22 23 at that time she says
Pat one of my goals in life is to stop
human trafficking I said you're 22 years
old what why why humans are Patrick
that's my goal I want to stop that
because it's not fair what they're doing
and you know how many times she talked
about it she's talked about Mario how
many times does she talked about it
always gotta be effective there's gotta
be a back
no the Baxter but there's got to be a
backstory to it right so when you hear
these stories if you've not been
involved in it or if you've not had
somebody that's been involved in it you
don't really think about it as an issue
until somebody does when you watch your
friend yakuza story and his sister went
you know and then she was missing for
eight years and after they found her and
how suicidal she was and how they had to
work with that it's pretty challenging
but here's what I will tell you here's
what I will tell you with this part I'm
gonna take it a different direction
over under how many days is she gonna be
alive before we hear the reporter she
committed suicide that's the real
question
how long do you think I do you think
she's gonna come out alive do you think
she's gonna be alive for a year six
months three months six weeks four weeks
what do you think
Epstein went to jail all of a sudden
committed her and impact everybody knew
he was gonna commit suicide before he
committed oh this is bad no this is
bigger though because bigger than
Epstein no no this is this is scarier
than Epstein because she she comes from
a family where her family's active dad
is actually rich and well-known and
she's kind of like listen and I don't
know how I got myself into this so
meaning Sammy talked to me Sammy the
bull Gravano shout out to Sammy if he's
watching as Sammy's obviously been on
vitamin before I said listen you know
here's what happened to Epstein and
you've been at the same place that he's
been at least I said what is the likely
of being able to hang yourself and
commit suicide he says I'm telling you
it's not possible it's not possible I've
been at that place I know where he's at
it's not possible how does he commit
suicide it's not but this is coming from
Sammy if you've now watch a video you
got to see Sammy's perspective on this
so now her max Walt goes out now the NEB
sank names that came out I don't know if
you saw the Prince Andrew interview that
was done about seven months ago if you
watch the interview you'll see he's
nervous and you see the pictures and all
that support that's Photoshop well
that's this Photoshop people know how to
look at pictures to see if it's
Photoshop or since it's very easy to do
that right so then you have other big
names coming up obviously Clinton's
involved in this okay that names come up
many many times she was at Chelsea
Clinton's wedding
yeah Kai if you could pull that up and
let me let me also her names came up
trumps conversations come up with hey
Melania and Maxwell and Epstein having a
picture right next to each other that's
her right there
at Chelsea's is at Chelsea's wedding
right there now I want to look there
there's all these people on the left
that are saying well there's a picture
of Epstein and trumpet together Pat
perfect okay Pat you so we both have
fairly large public followings okay a
few million each all right when we go
out to parties to did how many people
have you taken pictures with like that
that countless I mean just a ridiculous
number yes which is white whether
they're left or right I always say it
doesn't matter who you've taken a
picture with because when you have a
high public profile this is obviously at
a party everyone's looking at Trump
they're not looking at Epstein right
this guy over here is looking just
mesmerized to Trump like oh my god
that's Trump there okay so they take a
picture together everyone on the left
wants to use this picture to say oh
they're they their best friends but my
bluff Trump doesn't even really know
Epstein in fact when he gets to know him
he Trump was the only one that
cooperated with the FBI and went and
said yo this dudes doing some bad stuff
this is on record but you're doing was
that I don't know like mm five years ago
yes yes Trump were not friends they
didn't know each other so he has
publicly made a comment like yeah he's a
great guy he's fun to hang around he
said likes the younger girls just like
me if something like that has me that
okay you can look look but you don't see
Trump inviting his madam to their
flippin wedding like there's a huge
difference between taking a picture with
somebody and inviting somebody to the
wedding who else is on this list guy
while we keep going up it keeps growing
up yeah yeah I keep going up let's see
wells okay you got making a little
bigger make a little bigger resume in a
little bit all right okay keep going up
slowly just to give a little context for
the listeners out there
Harvey Weinstein which makes sense so
just just to give some context David
it's the koch brothers by the way one of
the things that Epstein was doing
was allegedly he was making tapes of
these people with underage girls and
then he was blackmailing them so I think
that's important context for some of the
people that don't understand the
totality of the story is that Epstein
was getting these guys luring them to
Lolita Island saying look here's all of
these young hot chicks and are underage
taking videos of them and then you and I
both know the minute that you have a
video like that that you don't want to
get out you'll vote however they want
you to vote you'll do your now owned now
Epstein or whoever controls Epstein is
the puppet master yeah these pictures I
mean again the pictures don't tell the
whole story
what will tell me the whole story is who
has visited his Island that's what tells
me the whole story that's the one I mean
your Tama gates you're talking about
clearly and Clinton was there something
had a painting go to go to Bill
Clinton's painting just type in the
Epstein Clinton painting which is I
don't know have you seen his painting
before uh Adam have you seen it when
they looked at Epstein's house this two
painting they found in the house go to
images this the painting they found in
his house no joke click on the painting
and he's wearing the infamous blue dress
make it bigger it's a famous line use
that that property make it bigger there
you go all right right there that's a
painting on the wall okay it's a pretty
weird painting to have your friend on
the wall it's kind of like you having a
painting of Mario on the wall with the
you know in a dress so I have it a point
here on obscene because I haven't
attempted to watch the the filthy-rich I
got through one episode I haven't really
followed it I don't know if this is a
political story as much as this just a
story of the wealthy and the powerful
okay so he's listen let me tell you
something if this if this girl
jillaine maxwell will figure out how to
say her name she's she's in all these
photos she's not some random chick that
happened to pop into a photo
she's with Jeffrey Epstein everywhere
she goes she's taking photos with Martha
Stewart with Naomi Campbell she's she's
in that rich and powerful world facts
you
so it's not a political thing for me
it's that when you become so in that
world entrenched in that rich and
powerful scene no one gives a [ __ ] if
you're red or blue no one cares
you're in the party welcome to the club
weird point my point is you're giving it
oh jeez at the Clinton wedding she could
have been a Republican event she could
it's she's at high-profile events she's
at high-profile rich and powerful events
it's for me it's not political a Clinton
wedding is not something that you just
imagine Allah get on the guest list my
point is this is obviously political
what that she knows the Clintons down
with the Clintons I'm just saying she's
in that rich and powerful world I'm not
talking it's all about the green at that
point it's not about red or blue at that
point I will I will agree with you on
this point is that we got a winner so is
that when when you get in that rich and
powerful world it's funny how
Republicans and Democrats can be best
friends behind closed doors and then
they can go out and pretend but look
here's the reality of politics ladies
and gentlemen and if you want to put the
camera on me I'm gonna perfectly explain
it to you for one second here here's
politics okay over here you've got the
Democrats over here you even have some
of the Republicans and they're talking
back and forth like this all right but
in reality if you were to zoom out
you're gonna see it's one guy in the
background that has a lot of money that
has his hands up both of their butts and
he's making their mouths move all right
this is the reality of the world that we
live in when it comes to the rich and
the powerful unfortunately a lot of
these guys that get into office are not
as principled as some of the others are
in their control because everyone wants
what sex money and power right and so
once they get into office all of a
sudden here comes a guy there's even a
joke in the lobby world Pat you can buy
any congressman for a couple hundred
thousand bucks because a lot of these
guys have like they've been somewhat
successful but I mean a lot of dummies
get into Congress too and you just go
over these are guys that are voting on
the most like the most powerful country
in the world the laws for the most
powerful country and you can buy them
off by by corporations which is why we
need to get back to a place to where we
are
to cut off money and some of the money
that flows in I dare you I challenge
people to go look at how congressman can
still take money from corporations
legally and you're talking to a guy that
was about to run for Congress because
these guys getting Congress and they're
not principled or they hook up with an
Epstein and guess what they stick the
little pecker and there's something that
they shouldn't and guess what happens
someone gets a photo of it or evidence
of DNA address and now you own them
[Music]